hi guys so I just wanted to make a quick
little vlog here a little vlog Yves la
Girton and say thank you all for being
so supportive with the charity water
event I know a lot of you guys are like
I don't have a credit card I don't have
any money I can't donate it doesn't
matter even just making these response
videos you're still getting the word out
and you're still gonna get to be a part
of the event because I'm gonna put you
in the video so I'm actually very
overwhelmed with how many video
responses I've got so far I don't think
I've ever got this many video responses
for anything ever so I'm extremely
excited that this community of people
are just so passionate and you guys are
great you really really are so thank you
again a few other updates I'm gonna be
posting a video tomorrow morning that is
for Valentine's Day so I've some some
fun little treats that I want to give
you guys for Valentine's Day and have a
bunch of them so hopefully I can give
more things out than then I pod shuffle
since I only had two of those um ii know
this would be the third thing i didn't
want to do this but i might and you guys
have all been waiting patiently for the
ask IJ show well i've got the theme song
my friend jeff smith made me this and he
is he's amazing
i don't know if I shouldn't well okay
I'll just play it for you
seriously I'm so excited I didn't want
to let you guys hear the song yet but
I'm kind of so excited about it that I
had to let you here so I'm gonna be
posting that video hopefully sometime
this week next week next week I'm gonna
be hosting the first episode next week
anyway um you can find Jeff with the
Jeff Smith duck and that's it that's all
I got um yeah thanks again for
supporting charity:water
thanks for just being amazing and that's
it okay bye
never gonna begin
you